Somali refugee Bader Hassan arrived in
Yemen 30 years ago it's been his home
ever since he survived through five
years of war but the economic impact of
the corona virus pandemic has pushed his
already precarious existence to the
limit he says he has no choice but to
leave I've worked in a coffee shop I've
done lots of jobs but now I'm back to
washing cars but even that's limited
because of the corona virus wherever I
go they ask what's your nationality
yemeni somali i say somali and they say
sorry goodbye life has become really
difficult there are more than 280,000
refugees living in yemen many like
baddha come from somalia the UN says
refugees are facing increasingly
difficult living conditions in the past
the refugees were well welcomed by the
Yemeni communities and the authorities
of course with the dire level of poverty
and know the corona virus there is more
and more discrimination and scapegoating
of this population coming from East
Africa alongside the refugees around a
hundred thousand migrants arrived in
Yemen each year but that figure has
declined in recent months because of the
global pandemic many are pushed by war
and poverty in the Horn of Africa they
choose Yemen because of its close
location hoping to cross into wealthier
Gulf countries in search of a better
life but now that dream is over about
250 of us took a boat to Yemen that cost
a lot of money five people died on the
journey once we arrived we headed
towards Saudi Arabia but the road was
blocked by the Hootie's they made us
turn back we have nothing to eat and
drink people are tired of helping us
they left their home for what they hoped
would be a life-changing opportunity
abroad but many say they no longer feel
welcome in Yemen and their only option
is to leave
Victoria gate and be al-jazeera